one dog being poisoned is a terrible
situation and as the owners said
previously they don't feel that it could
be another exhibitor and and we are
passionate about our dogs we love our
dogs and whilst we are extremely
competitive we we know out to harm dogs
for goodness sake people might have a
bit of an argument now and again but
it's certainly not going to affect that
the doc the dog is our love it's our
passion so it would be terrible if it
were in a fellow exhibitor but you know
there are cranks out there in all things
and people get the wrong idea about
cross and and think that it's just a
beauty show it certainly isn't it's
about a love of keeping dogs healthy fit
and and showing those attributes at
Crufts
basically so when you give the
celebration of dogs sorry yeah of course
if what will you say then that you you
doubt it was another exhibitor who I
mean who are these cranks that you
referred to who would come in and
sabotage an event like this would harm
dogs in this way who knows I'm not the
police and and I'm you know I'm not
absolutely don't have my finger on the
button of the full story here I'm
looking at it from the newspapers as
everybody else in the general public is
and it's a shocking event but I can't
comment further because I'm not sort of
affected in in a legal way in any fact
and so I'm only looking at the story as
you are but it's as a dog shell judge in
a dog show exhibitor I would hope that
it wouldn't be a competitor and that it
was some member of the public that had
sneaked in and done something dreadful
for whatever reason why do people hurt
dogs children or whatever as you say
it's a hugely competitive event and a
very popular one and there's a little
pressure on on the owners and the dogs
as well your experience is there enough
security across when it comes to put
petting the dogs and events like this I
mean it doesn't help hard take but
seriously enough the Kennel Club takes
it extremely seriously yes there is
immense security it is unseen generally
but I was sat in the stand watching best
in show last night and I was aware very
unobtrusive security was absolutely
everywhere absolutely everywhere
you know Crofts is a celebration of dogs
that a hundred and fifty thousand people
members of the public who attend this
wonderful event it isn't just a beauty
show it displays dogs in every aspect we
had friends for life people whose lives
have been enhanced and developed because
of their dogs that is part of their life
and police dogs who do wonderful work
people who do obedience agility heel
worked music all these events are there
and they helped and develop the public's
interest in what they can do with their
own pet dog at home which is absolutely
fantastic for dogs and dogs showing
generally it's not this simple beauty
event where breeders who have a purebred
dog exploit the dog
we don't exploit it we have a passion
for it we love it and we make out sure
that our dogs are as healthy as we
possibly can have them but we are
working with nature of course so she
always has the last word but you know a
dog a shell dog is a great thing for the
public because a show dog has to be
healthy otherwise he wouldn't be fit to
be shown he has to be faked
he has to have a wonderful temperament
to be able to mix with other dogs the
public going to places like the NAC
watch leave it there don't interrupt you
but we appreciate your time here at Sky
News tonight thank you